hello everyone this video is about
Sultan Khan and I'm sure a lot of you
probably never even heard of the guy but
his life story and his chess story are
simply too amazing not to tell I will
keep it short though he was a servant he
was servant to a to a British Lord in
India and he never learned how to play
chess he knew the rules of the Indian
chess but the rules of Indian chess were
different you had different promotions
you had the different stalemate in ideas
you had well the pawn could only move
one square not two squares but his
master knew that he was really talented
for Indian chess and so when his master
went to England he took him with him and
they organized the tournament he
gathered some British grandmasters and
they organized the training tournament
for Sultan Khan and Sultan Khan
performed very poorly here I think he
tied for last place but a couple of
months later he entered the British
Chess Championship and he won the entire
event I think winning all games and only
drawing one game so quite a spectacular
feat for someone who never actually
played chess and this game I'm gonna
show you now is played in 1930 so one
year after after he won the British
championship and in this tournament he
won third place ahead of him were only
two world champions maxilla and josé
raúl capablanca
and this game he's actually playing
against was a role Capablanca and he
beats him yes someone who never played
chess and he has been studying just for
a year defeated Jose roll kappa blanka
so let's see this game Sultan Khan is
white and capablanca is black we have
Knight to f3 Knight to f6 d4 b6 c for
Bishop to b7 Knight to c3 e 6 a 3 the 5
the Queen's Indian defense we have C
capture Sandy 5e capture sandy 5 and
Bishop g5 we have Bishop to e7 by kappa
blanka III couple Lanka castles Bishop
to d3 Knight to e4 Bishop to f4 Knight
to d7 Queen to c2 attacking the knight I
will have f5 by
Blanka night to be five threatening that
c7 pong as its attacked three times now
so kappa blanka plays Bishop to d6 we
have night capture Sundy 6c capture
Sundy six and h4 by Sultan Khan so rub
the c8 attacking the Queen Queen to b3
Queen to e7 night to d2 and ID to f6
Knight captures on e 4f captures on e4
and Bishop to e2 and now rook to c6
couple Blanca is prepared to double up
on the C file we have g4 by Sultan Khan
and now rook F the CA to doubling up on
the C file and Sultan Khan plays g5 we
have a knight to e8 and now Bishop to g4
attacking that rock and c8 and here is a
kind of a critical position of the game
cover the marketplace rook the c1 check
he wants to exchange this rook and also
get this rock out from from being
attacked by the bishop with the tempo
but Sultan Khan has a different idea he
plays a kink to d2 and this allows
Capablanca to to capture Sultan's Queen
and he plays rook rook to c2 check
photon Khan captures we have captured
and King captures and c2 and well Kappa
Lanka did win a queen but well he also
he also lost two rooks so we have Quinta
system in check we have King - D -
Quinta c4 now Bishop to e2 attacking the
Queen Queen to b3 now rook to be one
defending that be to pawn king to f7
replicate the c1 King t7r up to c3
kicking the Queen Queen to a4 b4 and now
Queen to d7 kappa blanka will try to you
know go go to the other side of the
board with the Queen we have a rugged b2
c1 and now Sultan Khan is controlling
the C file with his double crooks we
have a six rock - g1
Queen to a4 rope to c1 Queen back to the
seven and now Sultan plays h5 we have
King to d8 I wrote the c2 Queen to h3
King to see one Queen to h4 and for a
couple of moves now they'll be just you
know rearranging the pieces going for
some subtle subtle advantages but
nothing really too important we have
King to be to Queen to h3 r up the c1
Queen to h4 wrote the c2 Queen to h3 and
it's it's important to note that while
in this position kappa blanka doesn't
really have any plans he can't really do
anything only Sultan Khan can come up
with a plan so we have a four Queen back
to h4 King to a three Queen to h3
Bishop to g3 Queen to a5 Bishop to h4 a
g6 and now h6 Queen to d7 b v a5 Bishop
to g3 and Queen to f5 will have Bishop
to f4 Queen to h3 king - B - Queen - G -
and King to be 1 and this is kind of an
interesting position kappa blanka can't
really capture this f2 pawn here if
capablanca were to capture this pawn he
will get a Bishop to g4 attacking the
Queen from this rock and c2 and after he
would play something like Queen to h4
then simply Bishop to e6 and this is a
beautiful position as a couple banker
would be without a move so this Bishop
cannot move to any square this Knight
can't move to any square also and the
Queen has nowhere to go
the only place Queen can go is h5 but
then rook to h2 will capture the Queen
so it's a very difficult position for a
couple Blanca after this King to be one
so we have a queen back to h3 Queen to a
a king to a one Queen to G to King Tubby
- Queen to h3 r up to G one Bishop to c8
and now Rock the c6 as kappa blanka put
this Bishop on c8 now b7 is no longer
protecting c6 and this move is allowed
so he plays rook to c6 attacking this b6
pawn I will have Queen to h4 now Rob G 2
c1
Bishop to g4 and
Bishop to f1 Sultan doesn't want to
exchange this bishop of course we have
Queen to h5 now preparing Bishop to e2
so we have a rook to e1 defending this
and now Queen to h1 we have wrote back
to c1 Queen back to h5 and now King goat
goes to c3
we have Queen to h4 Bishop to g3 and
Queen captures finally on g5 and now we
have King Teti - now protecting a bishop
from ever going to e2 Queen to h5 and
our rook captures and b6 now this he
want is very important pawn and now he
created this strong b5 passed pawn we
have a king t7 Bishop to be roof to be
salmon check King t6 b6 Knight to f6 and
Bishop to b5 Queen to h3 and rook to b8
and in this position
Jose roll kappa blanka resigned as there
is there's no way to stop this pawn from
Queen only move would be something like
maybe Knight to d7 but then after rook
to e8 check and King to f7 simply b7
would be completely winning as the rook
cannot be captured if the King captures
the Rahman simply b7 b8 Queen and this
knight is pinned he cannot capture here
and if he doesn't do anything well
simply Bishop captures night and then b8
queen is on the board so a very nice
game bye-bye mr. Sultan Khan against the
former world champion josé raúl
capablanca
and like I said he finished third this
tournament but it was a very strong
tournament only players ahead of him
were the two world champions and Sultan
Khan played the chess actively in Europe
only for five years after that his
master took him back to India with him
and well no one ever heard of him there
is one story that while they were in
London that his master his master
invited the American chess team for a
dinner at his place in London and they
thought well yeah sure let's let's go
and we'll
you know hang out with Sultan play some
games but when they arrived
actually the his that master of his it
was just you know talking about himself
and well the only interaction they had
with Sultan Khan was when he was serving
them drinks and drinks and food so it
was a really awkward situation for for
the American chess team
yeah and it's you know who knows what he
might have accomplished if he stayed in
Europe and if he wasn't a servant by
their law I will put a description I
will put a link in the description of
this video so we can read more about the
guy it's it's quite a fascinating story
and yeah I hope you enjoyed this video
it isn't a fancy game as you would maybe
enjoy it but you can't really beat a
beat how they roll kappa blanka you know
in a couple of moves so it's a well
deserved victory indeed by Sultan Khan
so yeah that's it for this video as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon